سلمى منذ بدايه الحرب والتحذيرات تتوالى
بخصوص المستشفيات في غزه كيف يبدو الوضع
الان الوضع سيء جدا مستشفى الصداقه التركي
لعلاج مرضى
السرطان توقف عن العمل وخرجت وزاره الصحه
في القطاع لتحذر وتقول بان المستشفى
الاندونيسي ايضا في قطاع غزه توقف المولد
الرئيسي فيه عن العمل اي يعني الامر بات
مهددا داخل المستشفى لكل المرضى في داخله
يضاف ذلك ايضا الى ما تحدثت به وزاره
الصحه في القطاع عن نفاد الوقود ايضا بعد
ساعات قليله عن مستشفى الشفاء ما يهدد
ايضا المولد الرئيسي في مستشفى الشفاء
بالتوقف عن العمل ويهدد الالاف من الحالات
الموجوده داخله من المرضى والجرحى كل ذلك
يضاف الى ما يعانيه القطاع نتيجه نتيجه
استمرار عمليات القصف الاسرائيلي التي
بطبيعه الحال لا تتوقف في اماكن مختلفه من
القطاع من الشمال الى الجنوب تركز القصف
على محاور عده في قطاع غزه مستهدفا
الاماكن السكنيه حتى بالقنابل الفوسفوريه
التي تابعناها على شاشه الجزيره والتي
تابعناها تحديدا في منطقه الزيتون التي
تعرضت حي الزيتون تعرض بالتحديد لقصف مكثف
بالقنابل الفسفوريه هذه القنابل هي قنابل
محرمه دوليا من الاستخدام خاصه في المناطق
الماهوله بالسكان وبطبيعه الحال هذه
المناطق هي ماهوله بالسكان السكان لا
يستطيعوا التحرك والنزوح الى مكان اخر
بسبب محاصرتهم من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من محاور الشمال ومحاور الجنوب
في مدينه غزه كل ذلك ايضا يضاف الى ما جرى
الحديث عنه من مركز الاورو متوسطي لحقوق
الانسان الذي قال بان هناك
في قطاع غزه قامت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالقاء قنابل يعادل وزنها
25000 طن من المتفجرات والذي يقدر بما
يساوي قنبلتين نوويتين على قطاع غزه بهذه
المساحه الصغيره